the eight news now investigators are
looking into exactly who killed a 12
year old boy who was kidnapped in
November of 2020 the kidnapper or
Henderson Police eight news now
investigator Kyle Payne was at a
fact-finding review today where police
say the kidnapper fired the Fatal shot
here's what we do know before 12 year
old Joseph awadeame was kidnapped his
captor killed the young boy's mother
shot his sister and killed another woman
but we don't know is who exactly killed
the child we want to warn you some of
this video is disturbing
getting the kid out that was the topic
of today's hearing at the Clark County
Government Center where an assistant
district attorney led a Henderson police
detective through the wild violent chain
of events that led to the death of
12-year-old Joseph hawatami and his
armed kidnapper 38-year-old Jason Neo
born okay ma'am I have officers coming
the hawada May family couldn't bear to
watch some of the four-hour hearing
we're trying to make contact with the
Escalade keep it but they sat through
every minute of it
which was heavy on body cam video
9-1-1 calls here you see the photo of
the black Escalade and forensic evidence
were you able to determine who you
believed to be responsible for those
gunshot wounds yes the investigation
revealed that we believe Jason Bourne
was responsible for those gunshot wounds
the detective's belief still not perhaps
a concrete answer to the family's
question of who killed Joseph owatame so
we followed up with Clark County
district attorney Elizabeth Mercer are
you 100 sure that the police didn't kill
the boy the detective is 100 sure it
sounds like the question of whose
bullets actually killed Joseph also
remain very much unanswered did you find
the bullets that killed the boy
did the police find the bullets that
killed the boy
were no bullets
the young boy's family and their
attorney did not want to go on camera
today but their attorney told me their
forensic experts are waiting for
Henderson to release more evidence the
family has filed a civil rights lawsuit
where they allege the boy was killed by
bullets from Henderson Police
Kyle Payne 8 News Now
the police detective at today's hearing
was also cross-examined by an ombudsman
representing the people of Clark County
and he focused some of his questioning
on why no hostage negotiation took place
before police opened fire it's also
important to point out these district
attorney fact-finding reviews do not
determine whether any criminal conduct
occurred the DA's office has already
cleared the officers before today's
hearing